have you ever heard of a service called
protonmail protonmail was essentially
designed to be a better version of Gmail
from every aspect for example protonmail
don't even ask for a name to open a
protonmail email address additionally
all of the emails that you send and
receive are completely end-to-end
encrypted which is not the case with the
Gmail but the average person has never
even heard of this service the reality
is that while people hate that their
data is being collected they've also
gotten used to all the conveniences that
come along with that besides the hurdles
around to getting people to pay for an
email service are simply too much to
overcome